des secouristes armée de masques à gaz
des victimes contaminé par des
substances radioactives
c'est le scénario que tout le monde
redoute dans la plus grande centrale
d'europe à zaporizhya dans le sud est de
l'ukraine dont élise nous devons nous
préparer à tous les scénarios possibles
fin juillet la tension est montée d'un
cran autour de la centrale de zappos
ridja sous contrôle russe depuis le mois
de mars les deux camps s'accusent
mutuellement de bombardements autour du
site nucléaire ces dernières semaines
plusieurs frappes ou même atterri à
proximité d'un bâtiment abritant des
substances radioactives
occasionnant notamment l'arrêt d'un des
réacteurs de quoi craindre le pire
d'autant que les russes sont accusées
par les ukrainiens d'y stocker des armes
lourdes
il utilise maintenant le terrain autour
de la centrale nucléaire
ce que nos jeunes de rassemblement et
comme plateforme pour lancer des
attaques d'artillerie sur les forces du
craignait ce qui est imprudent et
irresponsable
il est urgent d'autoriser l'inspection
par l' agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique
en scénario à la portée des autorités
ukrainiennes selon le président et lens
qui
traîne est prête à garantir un contrôle
approprié de la centrale par l'aiea
c'est la mission peut être envoyés à la
centrale de zaporijia de manière légale
très rapidement donc aussi efficacement
que possible
la situation autour de la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja devrait
également être au menu des discussions
ce jeudi le secrétaire général des
nations unies antonio guterres s et le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan sont
attendus à lviv dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine